Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Bon ben toute l'équipe de zeste de sciences est partie en vacances.
Voilà. Sauf moi. Merci les gars.
Et du coup, je me suis dit que plutôt que de vous faire un épisode sur la solitude
et la nocivité de partager des photos de
vacances sur facebook,
je suis allée dans les archives et je
vous ai trouvé
des vieux épisodes  de Zeste de science.
A l'époque ça s'appelait
Ecorces de recherche.
Alors je vous laisse visionner.
Nous sommes en 1951 et les derniers
miracles de la technologie permettent
désormais aux savants de voir le son.
Toutes nos salutations cher spectatrices
et spectateurs.
Imaginez un instant : Vous vous rendez
dans une salle de concert pour apprécier
la quatrième symphonie de Brahms, et là
quel malheur vous n'entendez pas
les envolées lyriques des violons mais un
brouhaha insupportable,
sans compter que votre voisin mange
bruyamment du maïs soufflé.
Pour s'assurer que toutes salles de concert
ou de conférences jouissent d'une qualité
acoustique irréprochable il faudrait
d'abord mieux comprendre la propagation
du son à l'intérieur de celle-ci.
Sauf qu'il y a un léger problème :
le son est invisible.
Vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais le son se propage sous forme d'ondes.
Regardez bien ces images :
Vous êtes maintenant sous mon contrôle
vous allez
faire exactement ce que je vais vous dire.
Abonnez-vous !
Non, c'est une farce.
Il ne s'agit pas d'un dispositif de charlatan hypnotiseur
mais bien d'un simulateur d'ondes sonores,
utilisé par le centre de recherche
Scientifique Maritime et Industriel de
Marseille.
Et ce système déborde d'ingéniosité.
Parfois il déborde réellement.
Il s'agit d'une cuve à fond plat et transparent
remplie d'eau, éclairée par un arc électrique.
Je vous présente la cuve à rides :
Et lorsque je dis à rides, je ne parle pas
de désert
je parle des rides qui sont produites à
la surface de l'eau.
Ce sont elles qui représentent les ondes sonores.
Voici l'image des rides projetées sur un écran.
Lorsque l'on place une surface,
l'équivalent d'un mur dans la cuve à rides,
les réflexions des ondes
provoquent des interférences gênantes.
Elles se traduisent par un dessin en
damier occupant la plus grande partie
de l'écran. C'est là où les sons se
mélangent.
Pour tester l'acoustique
d'une mauvaise salle de conférence,
les scientifiques ont placé une maquette de cette salle
au sein du dispositif.
Voyez l'enchevêtrement problématique
des ondes réfléchies.
Une étude préalable sur la maquette
aurait donc permis d'éviter les erreurs
de construction.
Ceci est donc habile et utile.
Une surface spéciale comme celle-ci
appelée polycylindrique
diffuse les sons uniformément dans toutes les directions.
On utilise notamment des murs de cette
forme dans les studios de radio-diffusion.
Mais attention : nos chercheurs
du Centre de Recherche Scientifique
Maritime et Industriel de Marseille
ont plus d'un tour dans leur sac,
c'est à dire
plus d'une maquette dans leurs laboratoires.
Cette fois les chercheurs vont réussir
à créer un modèle de la répartition du son
dans une pièce.
C'est donc une autre
façon de voir le son avec les yeux.
Et plutôt que d'utiliser des rides sur
l'eau,
nos savants utilisent des ultrasons dans l'air.
Ces sons sont tellement aigus
que nous autres humains ne pouvons les entendre,
contrairement à nos compagnons
à quatre pattes.
Je parle bien entendu de nos chiens et non pas de nos chaises.
Réfléchis par la surface a étudier, les ultrasons
sont captés par un microphone
comme vous pouvez le voir
sur cet admirable graphisme explicatif
le microphone est mobile et va explorer
l'espace par ligne parallèles.
Ce microphone
va alors commander l'intensité lumineuse
d'une petite lampe, qui va se déplacer
devant du papier photographique.
Ainsi le papier va enregistrer la répartition des
ondes sonores dans la salle.
Voici les résultats :
on appelle cela
la topographie acoustique d'une salle.
Vous savez maintenant que grâce
à différents modèles réduits, les savants
peuvent désormais mieux comprendre
la réponse acoustique d'une structure et
-espérons le- nous permettre de mieux
profiter de nos concerts et nos
conférences scientifiques.
Ce sont donc des recherches qui
certainement vont faire du bruit.
N'oubliez pas de brancher votre
transistor sur la bonne fréquence
pour ne manquer aucun épisode d'écorce de
recherche.